where you guys from indiaia India India
everybody here from India India where do
you guys want to go in the United States
what city California California
California everybody here California New
Jersey Seattle yor New York you want to
work you want a job yes no what no you
don't want to
work why' you life danger life in danger
okay so you're here to seek
Asylum one day Crossings at our Southern
border were what about 1,500 daily but
on Monday they jump by almost a factor
of 10 to nearly
13,000 so what's the real reason for
this massive and sudden surge well
Customs and Border Patrol is telling our
own bill maluan that Smugglers are
purposely overwhelming the Border in an
effort to guarantee Mass releases of
humanity all at once for instance in the
Del Rio sector alone migrants from from
28 countries have been encountered at
the border most of them don't speak
almost a word of English among those are
folks from a tiny African country using
a loophole to gain entry into the
country these are the citizens of Sagal
and they're getting here via pseudo
legitimate travel agencies that are
advertising visa-free travel to the US
where they're then connected with human
Smugglers at the border joining me now
from Eagle paath Texas is alen Cabello
he's an independent journalist who's
been cing the crisis from both sides of
the Border alen what are your sources
telling you
tonight well there are several things
are one is uh to Bill malan's Point I've
been to tapachula and they're in
tapachula they actually have uh
psychologists that are training and
coaching these migrants on what to say
and what not to say as you can see in
Bill's uh video initially they speak
English and all of a sudden they they
forget English um and that's exactly
what I saw in tapachula that these
migrants are being trained and coached
and what to say the only difference is
that now here in pgas when I'm with them
on the on the Mexican side and they're
about to cross they they talk freely and
they they're telling me they're coming
here because they're seeking a better
life better opportunities better
education for their kids um and not
necessarily because they're fleeing uh
any other requirements necessary to seek
Asylum well they they know what to say
to qualify for Asylum this is all you
know this is all a game you like I my
life in danger I mean they're just going
to say that because they know that'll
maybe help their Asylum claims but my
sources in El Salvador out in are
telling me that these are mostly men
from certain African countries are
actually flying by the thousands into
Central America places like Nicaragua
and then they're working their way up
here but they're flying into Central
America to come into the United
States
that's exactly right there actually uh
pseudo uh travel agencies that are cing
these migrants to fly especially into uh
Nicaragua and then from there they're
taking all Central uh Central America
and ending up in tapachula and what
happens in tapachula chapas is that from
there depending on their resources they
get filtered to different border towns
for example what we're seeing here in P
neas is mainly Venezuelans who are uh
the poorest of the poor and that's why
they're arriving on the freight trains
um and then what you see in lukeville
Arizona or California is those that that
can afford paying a Smuggler $10,000 and
up and um these numbers are pretty much
the same uh what we're seeing here in
Eagle Pass and and also in Arizona so
the major uh Hub which is tapachula is
once again filling up because uh
immigration offices are completely shut
down until after January 6 when they
open up then you're we're going to see
another wave coming of those that are
stuck right now in to
uh and we'll see them here at the border
country yeah well I mean it's not a
country I mean we see to be a country
when we cease to control our borders but
you talk about something called the
selfie effect that's happening after
they cross what what is
that so that's exactly right uh as soon
as the migrants cross from P neas into
Eagle Pass I I usually take video of
them and the first thing they do as soon
as they cross is they take a selfie they
get on the phone call the relatives and
saying I'm in the US and that's the
messaging that's getting back to their
relatives and other migrants saying
they're made it they made it in let's go
um they're not listening to politicians
here in the US they're they're listening
to exactly they're listening to to their
own
messaging aen thank you for being there
and Reporting on this this is a Calamity
of National Security economic
proportions and of course it's a
horrible humanitarian issue as well out
and thank you hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else